probably gonna embarrass myself I used
to be a white guy in a band full of
white guys so this is my jam these guys
don't look like they'd be One Republic
based on their music I'm gonna say that
this is the frame oh this is one
director One Republic yes I know that
one dude and one Republic wears a hat
all the time I thought they were like
three people in one Republic or one
it could be LJ but look okay so it looks
like these people are around their
shortest friend and he's pregnant and
this is their announcement oh man this
is hard now they're all white they all
exhibit
it's either fossa the people are imagine
dragons and I think it's imagine dragons
this one is imagine dragons will imagine
that I was wrong telling you that one
performance I saw with them in Kendrick
Lamar this is what those guys look like
very acoustic looking I don't think this
is the fray but I know that there might
be a bald guy in the fray I'm gonna give
a really stupid reason and set there's
one guy and two others I feel like one
of them is Mumford and then they're the
sons this is the fray because that's the
lead singer and he's bald and has a
fresh-faced look make this hard and
where's the challenge see they're all J
or Bastille I think I might get this
wrong I feel terrible final answer for
this one is Arctic Monkeys I'm going to
guess that this is all Jake I know they
look really like grown and sexy and I
feel like this feels like a grown and
sexy kind of group
oh man it's Bastille Man there too I
don't want them to be this clean-cut
okay these people look just like
Bastille I'm pretty sure you're playing
a trick on me I see that they won two
Grammys apparently I feel like Vampire
Weekend is maybe the biggest name so I'm
gonna go with them I went to a Christian
college where everybody's indie it has
to be Mumford and Sons I I kept getting
it confused with Sanford and Son so
that's why I didn't go for that what's
interesting is that the frontman is very
recognizable and some of them to me but
if you like took him out I wouldn't know
I went back through all of these I would
still give you wrong answers I'm sure I
wouldn't remember who any of these
people are maybe I should broaden my
horizons a little bit listen to a few
more genres of the Medus familiar with
actually the Rockaways like to get some
diverse people in these bins man there's
lots of different cultures and
ethnicities the play music